The Joe Rogan Experience a family was
able to make so much money how much
money did they make in total I mean you
who you if you if you Google their value
it's between 10 and 20 billion reported
nobody knows exactly how much they're a
really secretive family one of the most
internet scrubbed families and Richard
tackler in particular people I've ever
encountered you just can get very little
information on them wow but um
you know and and any other I think big
part of the story that that surprised me
was the FDA right and the fda's role in
in opioid approvals and in the case of
Oxycontin uh you know we think about
like the FDA as this big giant
bureaucratic organization and you know
you'd think we were talking about stem
cells a little bit earlier yeah that if
you want uh to get an approval for a
drug you know well okay you gotta send
it to the FDA and it's going to be
reviewed by this massive Board of
scientists and you know experts and
they're going to make a determination
after careful analysis right that's not
how it works and in the case of
Oxycontin the whole approval process
came down to this one guy this guy named
Curtis Wright
and uh Curtis Wright when the in
um Purdue Pharma needed the FDA to
approve they'd spent 30 million bucks
developing this drug it's the whole
business of drug developing is
fascinating but they were all in and
they needed this drug and to keep the
company alive they needed the FDA to
approve it and this guy was like I can't
approve this this is heroin in a pill
no well and they kept trying to get him
to approve it and kept trying to get and
he started trying to like pump his ego
up they started writing articles with
them they started trying to you know
schmooze him and charm them he wouldn't
approve it finally and no one knows the
facts they took him to a hotel on the
East Coast Purdue Pharma took Curtis
right of the FDA spent a couple of days
in this hotel room they came out of the
hotel room with an approval with the
language
Oxycontin quote is believed to be
non-addictive is believed if you think
about that language it had never been
used in an approval process before ever
made no sense is believed not is not but
is believed to not be addictive a year
later he leaves the FDA was making
probably 50 Grand a year
where does he go work
Purdue Pharma for 400 plus thousand
dollars a year
they bought the approval but the two
days in the hotel what the [__] did they
do nobody who agrees to stay in a hotel
for two days or so I I wrote a scene in
in painkiller act we we were putting it
together
uh
where we imagined what happened in that
hotel right and I had like everything
from monkeys to like
like
kickboxing tie kickboxing massage
parlors to like everything we and like I
wanted to film the most debaucherous
two-day
like anything your mind could think of
like the craziest of the create right
water sports all of it all of it a lot
like like jet water sports whether they
spray your house down those sandblasting
ones yeah like just the crazy thing and
we wrote it like this just Faustian orgy
of absolute decadence and the lawyers
called and they're like are you [__]
kidding me we can't do this
so we just shut the door oh wow and we
just I think it's episode three that
that's it but he took a job but there's
conspiracies today that are real and
this Sackler family is one of the best
examples of one that was enormously
successful and worked on multiple levels
and this story about getting this
regulator to approve it by putting him
in a hotel for two weeks how the [__] is
that not illegal
like how is that not illegal I mean they
they handle themselves he he spent a
year still working for the FDA when
before he came and worked for um Purdue
and
um
pretty intense I just saw a video that
like I don't know whether it was TMZ or
somebody found the guy that um Curtis
Wright uh up in I think he's in New
Hampshire just like two days ago and
they like they kind of went after him oh
wow and I was like they're like what do
you say what do you have to say about
the show what do you what do you think
and um uh he like got in his car and
wouldn't talk and then they just
interviewed the local
um police chief for this town in New
Hampshire who said that well we had no
idea that this this guy's living in our
town I want to take him on a tour of our
morgue and our cemeteries and show him
uh show him
um you can I think you'll find Curtis
right if you look him up
um that is the definition of living in
hell yeah and now and and that's
you know I think that
people have asked you know like what
what is Justice what does Justice even
look like in a situation like this right
like if you're
that's the guy and the red that yeah so
that you know who plays them and that
was just uh that's the actual uh
gentleman who who approved it that's the
guy who was
went and worked for her so he just moved
to a remote Town moved to a remote town
and after our show came out I I think is
that a gun on his hip I don't think so I
tried what is that it's like a
flashlight he's got like a rig
looks like he's got his phone in the
front yeah he's got a whole vibe going
on and a passport filled with trips to
Thailand probably yeah
um right
but you know like that's that's that's
the face of a big part of the issue that
you know this guy was a bureaucrat
working for the FDA living his life and
you know the East Coast someone came
along and said hey you want to get out
of here you're making 50 Grand
this say that you believe this to be
less addictive that'll get us the
approval
and
you're good we're going to make you good
but here we are and that revolving door
still exists today that people go from
the FDA right into pharmaceutical
companies today for sure and it's so
weird that that's legal and another big
part of the game are these medical
journals right like there's something
called the New England Journal of
Medicine and like a big thing is for a
doctor in a new in some of these in
these journals are owned by the
pharmaceutical companies right so think
about it you own Purdue Pharma you
either buy or control medical journals
that write favorable articles about your
products about your drugs so in the case
of Oxycontin there was a small small
like almost a letter to the editor
written about Oxycontin being less than
one percent addictive in in the in a
medical journal which sounds like
official and like okay well damn Joe's
in the medical journal right let's go
these are controlled by drug companies
and they're not legit it's fake news
it's real fake news and it's all part of
the ecosystem of
selling drugs
and these are the big drug dealers like
we talk about chepo or Pablo Escobar you
know Eric Newman my buddy who was the
exact producer on this he produced
narcos and I was went deep on Pablo
Escobar and he's like when he when he
first said you want to do this he's like
these are the real drug dealers like
like these are the these are the drug
dealers putting up the real numbers and
they're the drug dealers who put their
name on museums like the Metropolitan
the Guggenheim the Louvre in Paris these
are like these are the the big time
hard-headed drug dealers they're real
gangsters no they're [__] gangsters
man it's such a gangster move to put
your name everywhere too uh-huh
especially on like education
institutions dude do you ever have you
ever been in the in the Metropolitan
Museum of Arts uh Temple of Denver the
giant glass it's the biggest exhibit in
the met in New York City and that was
the Sackler wing and I would go in there
when we were making the show and I was
it was this giant it's it's on the um
north side of the Met it's you it's a
massive art Wing and you go in there it
says the Sackler wing and you go in
there and there's parents running around
with their kids the last time I was
there I saw a guy get on his hands and
knees and propose and it's just this
happy joyful room built on
Oxycontin and two three months ago they
took the name down they finally took the
name down finally yeah for all these
years yeah so they've taken and and this
is the thing that like
what Arthur Sackler cared more about
than anything which is like the same as
Alfred Nobel right you know that Alfred
Nobel made dynamite that's how
he made his money it was a fascinating
story that Nobel was was the inventor of
dynamite it's almost like an
oppenheimer's situation I didn't know
that and the story is that someone ran a
false obituary they thought he died and
they called him a merchant of death the
great Merchant of death is gone this guy
Nobel who invented dynamite and at that
moment he realized [__] this is how I'm
going to be known this is going to be my
legacy The Merchant of death he took a
huge chunk of his fortune and started
the Nobel Peace Prize so when you hear
the name Nobel you don't think about
Dynamite right he invented dynamite hand
grenades and Howitzer Browns and
Munitions that was all Nobel now you're
just like oh my God Barack Obama just
won the Dalai Lama just won the Martin
Luther King and when like this guy made
it off a dynamite that's insane right
and so the sacklers were like the same
thing wait a minute we know what we're
selling here we know where our money's
coming from
look at that direction of death to
Pioneer of Noel prize that that the
Nobel Peace Prize was a big bait and
switch so nobody thought about the fact
that this dude you know
go look at the the body kind of Vietnam
and this is interesting he said many Saw
His invention what Alfred thought would
end all wars just like Oppenheimer as a
highly lethal product when Alfred's
brother Ludwig died in 1888 a French
newspaper accidentally published an
obituary for Alfred that referred to him
as The Merchant of death
wow
wow right did you know that I did not
that's a mind blower but it makes sense
because that's how evil [__] are
they'll try to cover up what they're
doing with humanitarian work a hundred
percent and that's what the sacklers did
very like okay we're selling heroin and
pills hold the word like 300 we're up to
300 000 deaths and a lot of wreck
families let's buy some art
let's put let's let's donate to multiple
medical schools get our names on medical
schools all around the country let's
throw our name up on the Metropolitan
Museum of Art the Guggenheim
um the the um Louvre in Paris they were
putting their names on anything they
could there was a bridge in London that
one of the sacklers the Sackler Bridge
like just anything to Take Your Eye Off
the ball and so to me
you know whether they end up paying 6
billion or 16 billion yeah that that
that's real that that's deserve money
but I think the the bigger issue is the
name the this the evisceration of the
name has
is is is in deep process right now as it
should be yes and I just wonder how
they're going to get away with without
paying criminal penalties I mean not
just criminal penalties but like going
to jail
it's hard to go to jail today if you've
got a lot of money Joe that's that's
yeah I mean it's a jet I I don't I can't
imagine the sacklers going to jail
but I think worse than
jail is the fact that the name is now
done yeah and that hurts because this
this was a family that was all about the
Legacy
that's over
um this guy that approved it what was
his name again Curtis right they found
imagine being that guy
because you didn't even get rich you
know you got kind of Rich you made a lot
of money but you didn't get like
billionaire I can just go hide on an
island Rich you're in a small town in
New Hampshire
and then they find you when there's this
here the series comes out yeah I I don't
I never know like
someone's morality like I always have
trouble like understanding how different
people process
morality and and like what it would mean
for because you gotta assume a guy like
that after
you know 25 years has figured out a way
of justifying to himself what he's done
right like we all do that like I mean we
justify our our behaviors oh we don't
engage in Behavior like that but we
whatever we do we justify it and I I
wonder how much it hurts you know like
we tried to contact Richard Sackler
several times during the early he used
to live here in Austin and
um we couldn't find him he has a house
here in Austin still
um but how how it feels you know there's
never been a moment where there's been
any kind of accountability where you
know Richard Sackler comes out and says
okay okay look I am really [__] sorry
let's just start with that I I I am so
sorry that this has happened I am so
sorry for the pain
like and I can't undo it but I want to
First acknowledge that I'm sorry I made
some really bad decisions I thought I
thought I was helping people I wasn't I
didn't there was never been and I think
that's where the anger comes from so
much of it